hi in this video I'm going to discuss a
question direct from IIT Jam 2016
biotechnology paper so this is this
question is apart for on NMR now they
give a structure and they labeled all
the hydrogen by a B and C now they ask
which of the options are correct so this
is a msq question that means multiple
option could be correct more than one
option could be correct now we have to
say which options could be correct now
we would analyze every option and we
would construct the NMR spectrum for
this molecule and we would see which
option is correct to build a NMR spectra
we first need to identify the different
hydrogen atoms and their environments
when we understand the environments of
the hydrogen ion then we can build a h1
NMR spectrum so the h1 NMR spectra of
this molecule would particularly look
likes on what so here we have these x
axis and in y axis y or x is he will put
ppm and here you put abundance but
forget about ppm let's say we just for
understanding purpose we are plotting
energy in the x axis so you would have a
reference peak over here very near to
zero and that you would called TMS peak
and other Peaks
you would have a peak over here then you
would have a pick some word here so what
do you mean by downfield and upfield so
here written downfield and half inches
so you have to understand about a
downfield and upfield peak so these
three peaks at the NMR spectrum for this
molecule now if we label the hydrogen
molecule so this peak that you can see
over here this is for the hydrogen's of
a this is for hydrogen's of the P and
this is for hydrogen of the sea
so any pick that is quite far away from
zero which poses high energy would be
termed as downfield
so this pick is downfield pick I mean
most downfield pick with respect to B so
with respect to B is downfield again
with respect to C B is downfield so
let's analyze the first option first
option says a is reasonable up to proton
C so they say that a is upfield than the
C and from this spectra you can see a is
actually down field is down field in the
spectra so this option could not be
correct so this option is wrong so how
would you know that a pick is down field
or up filled up it could have high
energy or low energy the trick is just
see the molecular environment here the
carbon is attached to bromine and as it
is a highly electronegative substance
bromine would pull the electron density
towards itself so here around carbon
there is a deshielded environment very
important so d shielded environment so
when there is a D shielded environment
around any atom so the peak
corresponding to it would be downfield
peak that is why we get most downfield
peak for a then if we talk about B are
the electron density shifted towards the
left but not as much as a so that is why
for this particular B hydrogen's we have
a peak a little bit upfield to a and it
has a little bit less energy than a
and the least energy is in see because
these electrons are not that much pulled
towards left so it is less deshielded it
is shielded environment this environment
is shielded and here the environment is
D shielded this environment is D
shielded if you don't know what
shielding and deshielding
you should watch my other videos in the
biophysics section however the trick is
you have to look about d shielded and
shielded environment if the environment
is shielded a thumb rule is the pick
would be upfield a pick would be very
close to zero and see this is a shielded
environment and the pick is very close
to zero and this peak is deshielded and
this pick is far away from zero and far
away from zero that is where the first
option is incorrect and let's see the
second option for terms of be resonant
down fill two protons of C so B is
downfield to see and as from the
spectrum you can see B is really
downfield to see because B is more
deshielded than C so B should be
downfield and C should be up filled so
this option is correct let's see whether
other options are correct or incorrect
there are two triplets and one quadrant
of the spectrum now this is very hard
triplet and quadrant what are these
these are actually fine splitting of
these Peaks so these triplet quadrate
everything is fine splitting of this
peaks we would analyze this option later
now let's come to D proton a appears as
our triplet with high chemical shift and
comparison to proton in C so we have to
understand splitting or JJ coupling so
this is a very hard concept but for
tracking this mcq you can take a very
easy example a very easy rule how you
can solve this so whatever you have
to do is for a peek to understand how a
peek could get finally splitted into
other Peaks you just look at its
neighbor hydrogen so how many hydrogen
are there neighbor to a so the A's
neighbor hydrogen are B hydrogen's so
there are two B hydrogen's and the rule
is called n plus 1 rule so now if we
want to know the fine splitting of a we
would use n plus 1 rule so which
hydrogen is neighbor to a these
hydrogen's so there are two hydrogen so
n is equal to 2 and 1 so there is a 3 I
mean is actually splitted in three peaks
so this a peak if we zoom this a peak
actually we would see some what it is
splitted in three peaks like these so
this is called triplet now let's analyze
the C peak so the nearest hydrogen to C
is also B is a hydrogen there are two
hydrogen so for if we are analyzed for C
it is n plus one rule and here is two
hydrogen near to see that means the B
hydrogen's and one so the total
splitting is three again that means this
C peak is also splitted into three small
Peaks so it is actually splitted in
three small peaks if we analyze it
closer and B is also splitted in small X
due to coupling spinning spin-spin
interaction but the problem is with B
you can't use the n plus one rule the n
plus one rule is not valid for B as for
B we have its neighbors on both sides so
C hydrogen's are neighbor of B and a
hydrogen's are neighbor of B so you can
use this type of n plus one rule but
what you can say that when this kind of
thing
you occurs you have multiple peak
multiple peak means more than six I
think so so here you have there are two
triplet yeah it's right and one quadrant
spectrum no it's not quadrant another
would be actually a multiple peak so
it's not quadrant yes there are two
triplet Peaks
peak of a and peak of see are actually
splitted into three fine Peaks so this
is correct but this quadrant this is not
correct so that is why this whole option
is incorrect now let's come to the
fourth option proton a appear as a
triplet with high chemical shift okay
here is an another new term chemical
shift we would in a moment see what is
chemical shift in comparison to proton
see proton a appears as triplet with
high chemical shift in comparison to
proton see so as you can see from the
spectrum proton see and put on a protons
of a and protons of C if we analyze
their spectrum both have triplet
splitting so this is correct
the triplet splitting is correct now
chemical shift chemical shift means the
peak of a particular thing is how much
shifted from the zero
how much far away from the zero in easy
word they are just asking how much
downfield the pic is so they said proton
of a appears as triplet and high
chemical shift in comparison to proton
see so the how much far away the proton
sees here from zero this much and how
much away proton a is from zero this
much so proton a has higher chemical
shift so chemical shift for proton a is
higher and both proton Peaks
corresponding to potent proton a and
proton see will split into triplet due
to spin-spin interaction that is why
this option is correct
so after analyzing the question this
question was pretty hard and
the correct answer is B and the correct
answer is D so these two answers are
correct I hope you understand why they
are correct are many things I've skipped
and I try to understand it in a bit
unscientific manner but these are just
tricks how you can crack this type of
hard MCQs in a moment hope that helped
you please like and subscribe for more
videos